Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Let's talk about the mathematical intricacies
of the elections!
Here you can see the shape of the twelfth
congressional district in North Carolina in
the 90's.
This is not a naturally shaped electoral district,
is it?
One might say this is more of an abomination.
If we try to understand why it has this peculiar
shape, we shall find a remarkable mathematical
mischief.
Have a look at this example of 50 electoral
precincts.
The distribution is 60% percent blue, and
40% red.
So this means that the blue party should win
the elections and gain seats with the ratio
of 60 to 40, right?
Well, this is not exactly how it works.
There is a majority decision district by district,
regardless of the vote ratios.
If the electoral districts are shaped like
this, then the blue party wins 5 seats to
zero.
However, if they are, instead, shaped like
this, the red party wins 3 to 2.
Which is kind of mind blowing, because the
votes are the very same.
And this is known as the wasted vote effect.
This term doesn't refer to someone who enters
the voting booth intoxicated, this means that
one can think of pretty much every vote beyond
50% + 1 to a party in a district, to be irrelevant.
It doesn't matter if the district is won by
99% of the votes or just by 50% + 1 vote.
So, the cunning plan is now laid out.
What if, instead, we could regroup all these
extra votes to win in a different district
where we were losing?
And now, we have ceremoniously arrived to
the definition of Gerrymandering, which is
the process of manipulating electoral district
boundaries to turn the tide of an election.
The term originates from one of the elections
in the USA in the 1800s, where Governor Elbridge
Gerry signed a bill to reshape the districts
of Massachusetts in order to favor his party.
And at that time, understanably, all the papers
and comic artists were up in arms about this
bill.
So how does one perform gerrymandering?
Gerrymandering is actually a mathematical
problem of the purest form where we are trying
to maximize the number of seats that we can
win by manipulating the district boundaries
appropriately.
It is important to note that the entire process
relies on a relatively faithful prediction
of the vote distributions per region, which
in many countries, is not really changing
all that much in time.
This is a problem that we can solve via standard
optimization techniques.
Now, hold on to your papers, and get this:
for instance, we can use Metropolis sampling
to solve this problem, which is, absolutely
stunning.
So far, in an earlier episode, we have used
Metropolis sampling to develop a super efficient
light simulation program to create beautiful
images of virtual scenes, and the very same
technique can also be used to steal an election.
In fact, Metropolis sampling was developed
and used during the Manhattan project, where
the first atomic bomb was created in Los Alamos.
I think it is completely understandable that
the power of mathematics and research still
give many of us sleepless nights, sometimes
delightful, sometimes perilous.
It is also important to note that in order
to retain the fairness of the elections in
a district-based system, it is of utmost importance
that these district boundaries are drawn by
an independent organization and that the process
is as transparent as possible.
I decided not to cite a concrete paper in
this episode.
If you would like to read up on this topic,
I recommend searching for keywords, like redistricting
and gerrymandering on Google Scholar.
Please feel free to post the more interesting
finding of yours in the comments section,
we always have excellent discussions therein.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!